I have two green balls and three purple
balls so how many balls do I have all
together well it's going to be two
purple sorry two green balls plus three
purple balls is going to be five balls
all together and you see that right over
there there's five balls all together we
can count them one two three four five
now what if we did something a little
different
let's start with the five balls so we're
going to start with the five balls and
you can count them again one two three
four five and now let's take away two
let's subtract let's subtract two of
these balls so let's take away one and
two
well then what are we left with well
then we are left with one two three
balls we're left with three balls and
you might already see a pattern here two
plus three is equal to five but if you
start with five and you take away two
you're going to be left with three look
at how this is arranged and look at how
this is arranged two plus three is equal
to five but 5 minus 2 is 3 5 minus 2 is
3 and it works the other way around if I
start with five if I start with five and
if I were to take away three so if I
subtract one two three what am I left
with
well I'm left with one two I am left
with two so two plus three is five three
plus two is five
we see that there which is a which is
another way of saying that 5 minus 2 is
3 or 5 minus 3 is 2 take a look at this
for a little bit this is a really really
important pattern or a really important
idea to understand in math if you add
two numbers and you get say if you're at
a 2 and a 3 or you add two numbers and
you get another number well if you take
if you take that number and you subtract
one of these you're going to get the
other number